so Google just flipped the tables on the
iPhone a little bit in the ongoing blue
bubbles versus green bubbles Saga so up
until this update iPhone's Android's
context with green bubbles and SMS but
when an iPhone user wants to react to a
text which is an iMessage feature the
Android User would literally just get a
separate text message that said Marquez
loved your message which like it made
sense but it's also just kind of
annoying as an Android User it would
just be one more reason you'd be
thinking about maybe just getting an
iPhone but Google's latest update to
their messaging app actually added
reactions support it literally
intercepts those text messages and then
just turns them into reactions which is
sweet except that now when the Android
User goes to react back to the iPhone
user's message the iPhone is now the one
getting the text message that Marquez
liked your message but for the first
time it is slightly more annoying to be
the iPhone user in this blue versus
green bubble situation
your move Apple